herbages signifie en créole remettent
pouvoir se soigner par les plantes est
une tradition à la réunion à savoir
souvent transmis de génération en
génération et qui perdure avec la
connaissance de nos tisaneurs
aujourd'hui partons à la découverte du
zumba ville
cette plante endémique de la réunion et
de l'île maurice pouces entre 1000 et
2000 mètres d'altitude
ses tiges sont pourvus de petites
failles dans tes avec à leurs extrémités
des fleurs de couleurs jaunes et
blanches serbie met en terre depuis
trois ans quatre ans à peu près et à 6 3
en 4 ans
la première fois qu'il ya pour tailler
la petite taille assez costaud c'est
serai à fond on maquille pas ça s'est
aussi plaint il a pas trop de monde pour
casser une jambe à vide ils poussent
dans les eaux c'est une plante endémique
de la réunion est une bêtise à ne plus
utiliser dans
utilisé en or et lionel bah bill avec
les fleurs jaunes comme titan mist qui
va aussi contribuer à babylone trophée
jaune se fait beaucoup de choses à 10h
12h baville lorsque un petit souvenir
d'enfance même en avoir huit ans devant
la gale qui est évidente en entendant
les années 60 et la vie bonhomme la rue
las cases avec un petit bonhomme à
vilain petit peu fumeterre est un petit
peu la chaux au bout de trois jours et
puis la gale c'était très très très dur
pour moi et de ma petite scène et l
envie depuis une semaine à s'offrir des
gal démangeait bon plus du stress
démangeaisons puce puce est incroyable
c'est la marque à moins parce que le
monsieur à peine j connelly a déconné il
connaît pas dire tu pouvais pas écrire
après les dégâts causés et mon
impression et je pose on dit ce monsieur
l'a connue et reconnue dans toute la
côte ouest
monsieur emile part c'est un grand
bonhomme parce que il connaissait la
forêt comme ça mais voilà dans ma ville
est très utilisée aussi dans tout et
tisanes soit diamètre que ça cholestérol
que ce boulet ce marché est ce ma maison
ma ville est très utilisé pour les
problèmes de peau aussi donc que ce soit
en interne ou en externe
nous on va vider partout dans la tisane
réunionnaise est presque partout pas
vraiment pas partout mais presque
partout dans les tisanes internes et
externes dans une petite idée
les problèmes de peau eczéma des binbins
exemple la ville associée avec d'autres
plantes
les personnes y voit l'effet au bout de
peu de temps une semaine deux semaines
trois semaines si la personne n'y fait
attention aussi à ce que tu y mettre
dedans su ce qu'ils mangent jambes avis
peut être un très bon complément un
complément pour finir avec des problèmes
de peau coûte tout est bon à la base il
m'a personnellement car on a une belle
jeune fille comme ça que ce soit le bois
lac ne voit le petit bois le petit tige
sur les feuilles les fleurs là c'est
vraiment juste à point parce que ces
moments-là petites fleurs comme ça
couper sa finement et faire sa
préparation
tout est bon là dedans moi jamais
utilisé la racine mais la machine sur le
fait d'être bonne pour quelque chose
mais en général on n'aurait pas tué le
piètre on va tailler de façon de faire
vos courses à savoir au bois joli but
victor
bon pas une préparation décoction là
nous va prendre l'eau froide que les la
nouvelle bouilloire et dans cette
bouilloire même temps nous va mettre des
plantes décoction de 120 minutes par
exemple des anomalies et fumeterre dans
ma ville et papa clapot l'avait lanouf
est rude lente comme ça pour à peu près
un litre et demi un litre un litre et
demi bon il me l'a s'est dit bien
décoction pour le bain litres un litre
et demi ne peut rajouter un petit porte
porte entrouverte bien fox et toc toc
fait au top non micky connais pas pop
rock la pop corn et pas de n'importe
quel carlton pascal un poison par les
producteurs donc veillez bien à ne pas
ramasser n'importe où le propos très bon
pour le psoriasis très bon poulet
problèmes de peau la nouvelle petite
apparition ne peut rajouter là tant
d'autres plantes mais là c'est pour
montrer comment nous fait une décoction
donc nous a versé l'eau de lavernose
dans l'eau est froide ne battait plus en
dedans nous recouvre la casserole voir
comment ça se fait dans une grande
marmite dans une grande casserole ne
fait ça pour 5 10 vite là c'est
démonstration de chauffe nous laisse de
l'eau bouillir 1 décoction dans cinq 5
minutes 10 minutes
mais bon c'est vrai qu'avant on avait
plein de la villa peu partout dans les
eaux qui commence et deviendra comment
elle est arrivée ici chez malades à 35
ans on avait des pizzas baville tout le
long du chemin lahoud images de la
maison ma ville sur le chemin là il peut
compter sur les doigts d'une main
combien de deux ans baby grèce donc
comme c'est une plante un petit arbuste
les très connus très utilisé nous on a
été réimplantée c'est ce que montre en
effet maman tf cette année une centaine
de piedmont encore le temps même plus à
implanter il pense que dans tous les
hauts de l'ouest là la vie à des eaux il
peut passer par jean babilée frère jean
pour commencer si donc on ne comprend
que l'avenir est là dedans l'avenir est
dans les tisanes sa maman est sûr et
certain que dans dix quinze vingt ans
devoir parler les hauts de l'île
pourrait retrouver notre valorisation à
côté d'un peu de géraniums votre petit
cultures associées
nous sommes avisés fait raison de notre
place planter des arbres demi finale
nous on va vivre le faire jeune william
aaron extra extra n'aurait de la place
et puis désarmée diffère aussi un noeud
bon miel bouillant bon miel vert là
c'est dans les eaux qui nous fait ça
voilà est-ce que mais il pourrait dire
que dans babine maintenant beaucoup de
chats faire pour apprendre encore babine
beaucoup d'eux a fait pour dia suis dans
ma ville a fait rire avec avec les
médicaments c'est marine fait